SARA VERRILLI: So
the course evolution
has actually been
more a refinement
than any really big evolution.
We've always had the
four project structure.
We have done some juggling
of the amount of time
allotted to each project,
and what we're asking
for the goals for each project.
The first year we
ran the course we
were kind of asking for
a full game prototype
from each of the iterations.
And we were asking
them to do everything
for every project, which was
a little much to ask them,
although they did it.
I mean, they did it.
We've been refining
each of the projects
as it goes to try to emphasize
a particular thing we're
trying to teach, especially
in the first three projects.
So the first project
is prototyping,
and the second project
is project management,
and the third project
is now user interface
and interactions,
feedback especially.
And then the fourth project
remains tie it all together
into one overall synthesis.
Also, I think that our
use of guest lecturers
has gotten better
over the years.
We've been able to
reach out to more people
and we've realized
more and more the value
that they bring into the
course, having people
to come in and talk, often
agreeing with what we've said,
but giving a
different perspective
and rooting it back
into the game industry.
The students really like to hear
that this is actually what's
going on in the game industry.
They're not just being taught
this stuff in a course.
PHILIP TAN: When we first
started teaching this class
we were primarily
looking at the skills
that MIT students
had and didn't have
when they came and joined our
lab as undergraduate research
assistants.
And we found that there was
a certain skill gap of things
that we had to teach every
single new student who came.
Even though they may have
been very skilled programmers,
they didn't understand what
it was like to work in a team.
And so a lot of the genesis
of this particular course
comes from just us trying to
increase that pool of students
that we could hire as
undergraduate researchers.
And of course, in the
process of teaching a class
about making video games,
a lot of the students
taking the class
were also interested
in working professionally
in the game industry.
And so we expanded the
content on the skills
that you're going to
need outside of MIT.
But we've always been
very, very careful
to make sure that a student
who comes out of that class
is in good shape to be able to
get a research internship here
in our lab.
RICHARD EBERHARDT: So this
semester, product three
is different than last year.
Last year the focus was
on the aesthetics, so
think about how art and sound
and visual combine to make it
an aesthetic experience.
That's not as important this
year for our final project.
So we changed it
to something that's
actually going to help them with
their final project a little
better.
So this case it's
user interface.
We're asking them to make
these decision making
strategy-like games.
There's going to be a lot
of elements on the screen
that a player is going to
have to understand immediately
what they do and how they
interact with each other.
So focusing on that user
interface and that user
experience is important
for us, and in
particular, feedback systems.
So because our theme is
meaningful decision making,
if I'm making a
decision, part of it
is I should know what the
decision was that I just made
and how it affected
the rest of the world
and how it affected my own play.
So that kind of reinforcement,
that kind of feedback loop
is going to be very important
for that third project.
PHILIP TAN: We've also
brought back something
that we temporarily
departed from,
and that's the idea of having
a client, a real client who
has a need for the games
that need to be made.
In reality, if you go out and
work in the game industry,
you're not making games for
yourself most of the time,
you're making games
for someone else.
So in this case, we're going
to be working with the Climate
Center and the
Humanitarian Response Lab
here at MIT to talk about
issues of climate change,
and more importantly about
preparing for disasters.
We feel this kind
of topical relevance
will make this class
additionally more interesting
for certain students
who aren't just
enamored with the technical
challenges of making a game.
But I think this might
also be the first time
that we specifically
had the client give us
a design theme as opposed to
a technology to work with.
RICHARD EBERHARDT: Yeah.
PHILIP TAN: So it's a
departure, but in many ways
it's taking what we've
learned from the previous two
iterations of this class
when we didn't have a client
or when we had students working
on a design theme rather
than a technology and putting
it together this year.